foreign
[Music]
's Precision cut slice technology allows
prolonged use of viable human organ
tissue to study disease biology and Drug
metabolism to study kidney disease our
patented PCS technology begins with
eight millimeter renal cortex tissue
cores these cores are cut into 250
Micron slices
next the tissue slices are cultured in
liquid media in fiberfine's patented
bioreactor
using this technology fiberfind is able
to maintain the structure viability and
metabolic functions of tissue slices for
up to seven days
during this time spontaneous progression
of pre-existing kidney fibrosis can be
studied in culture whilst addition of
pro-fibrotic agents to the culture media
can be used to model more advanced
kidney disease
accentuating fibrosis results in scar
formation in the tissue sample with
emission of secreted extracellular
Matrix proteins in the culture media
secreted inflammatory and fibrotic
proteins can be sampled daily and
measured to monitor disease progression
putative anti-fibrotic peptides small
molecules or antibodies can also be
introduced they may be added
prophylactically to inhibit fibrogenesis
or therapeutically to Halt fibrotic
progression of pre-existing kidney
fibrosis
the extended life of the physiologically
intact and metabolically active tissue
slices provides a window of opportunity
to test the efficacy of Novel drugs
targeting tissue inflammation or
fibrosis in this way fiber finds
pre-clinical platform is unsurpassed as
a bridge to clinical studies using
fibrefine's patented technology PCS
cultures have been successfully prepared
from a range of human organs this can
lead to novel Therapeutics in the
research of organ disease
for more information about Precision cut
slice technology contact fibrefind